hace 10 años me propuse iniciar una
revolución quería hacer realidad un gran
sueño mío que era crear un laboratorio
de innovación tecnológica donde
pudiéramos estar resolviendo problemas
super complejos ayudando a méxico y al
mundo a resolverlos con tecnología
incluso mi señor que siempre me echa
porras me dijo siéntate ándale es que tú
siempre estás a un paso adelante y yo
dije wow increíble ese es el nombre del
laboratorio innovación tecnológica se va
a llamar
aupa a un paso adelante entonces tomé
todos mis ahorros desarrolle varias
pruebas de innovación tecnológica y
actividad todos mis contactos para poder
comercializar mis soluciones y qué fue
lo que pasó
bueno después de um
de operación del laboratorio innovación
tecnológica logre vender muchísimo
vendí mi casa vi mi carro vendí hasta
una bicicleta vieja que tenía me fue
súper mal y no vendí esto para quedar en
ceros o en tablas no no no lo vendí
quedando en una deuda sumamente grande
con todos los ahorros de una vida y dos
ya
graves problemas familiares y incluso
graves problemas de salud de ser una
persona que era súper aventada para
adelante es súper optimista súper
propositiva ahora me daban ataques de
pánico y de ansiedad todos los días
y recuerdo
y yo nada más me decía llamados a ser un
gran emprendedor que está totalmente
fuera de las cartas el que se hace un
empresario y un además me decía no
sirves no sirve es más hierbas
y recuerdo una noche
haber estado dentro de la regadera
recargado deteniéndome de las paredes
con el agua cerrada
y solamente pensando
como llegué hasta aquí para como me fue
tan mal
y tan rápido
y ojalá les pudiera decir que ahí tuve
un momento eureka y que llegó una
solución y le dije a esta es la manera
en la que estaba resolver pero no esta
situación duro y duró mucho tiempo
incluso en ese tiempo a alguien que en
ese momento yo lo considere como un
consejo muy crítico me dio una
recomendación de un consejo donde me
dijo williams es que tú siempre quieres
andar haciendo soluciones galácticas
siempre quieres salvar al mundo siempre
quieres pegar brincos inalcanzables
ok
pensemos en esto un poco
en las resoluciones galácticas y querer
salvar al mundo no tiene nada de malo
e incluso hay empresas a las que les ha
ido bien haciendo eso entonces porque no
lo podía hacer yo
pero la última parte del consejo sí me
pareció interesante eso de querer ver
brincos inalcanzables
y entonces aquel nerd dentro de mí y me
puse a generar hipótesis y dije bueno
pues vamos a ver qué es lo que hace a
los grandes emprendedores lo que son
grandes emprendedores y pero simple
había como que un misticismo en donde el
emprendedor se le ocurre una idea la
persigue incansablemente y después de
superar algunos obstáculos la logra web
pensamiento completamente lineal eso a
mí no me servía
yo creía haber tenido ya ideas las había
perseguido se instrumentó
incansablemente y había fracasado
entonces será momento de cambiar
de fuente y dije bueno pues la
naturaleza es exitosa vamos a ver qué es
lo que hace en la naturaleza
y dentro de la biología me encontré con
un concepto que me parecía muy
interesante que se le llama el futuro
adyacente posible
y esto es porque la naturaleza si está
mejorando se día a día con este con
mejoras incrementales pero para generar
organismos que sean más exitosos tenga
brincos en la medida de lo posible con
reactivos que están a la orilla de su
acceso
ok entonces parecía tener algo ahí
parecía tener algo que sí podía servirme
pero a mí me habían enseñado dos tipos
de innovaciones la incrementan y la
destructiva y pues en la incremental
está muy claro hoy yo quiero llegar allá
me queda muy evidente a donde quiero
llegar me quedan claros los pasos que
tengo que seguir si fuera llegar al
segundo piso de tu casa
bueno pues vas por una escalera que
estaba por ahí que la conoces
perfectamente la colocas de piso a techo
sabes que quieres llegar al segundo piso
ves los veinte peldaños de la escalera
los caminas llegas al segundo piso
innovación incremental
pero en la innovación disruptiva el
objetivo no está muy claro y puede estar
lleno en el segundo piso de tu casa si
en donde el piso sigue siendo un
rascacielos allá con el 29 en su oficina
y ya no te sirve la escalera que tienes
guardada en tu casa ahora necesitas una
escalera que te permita recorrer esos
100 pisos
y si existiese tal escalera y las
lograrás poner enseguida de ese edificio
de todas maneras los pasos están claros
los primeros dos o tres pisos pero más
para allá
todo está borroso no tienes claros los
pasos que tienes que tomar para poder
llegar hasta ahí arriba incluso una meta
no es clara estar en el piso 100 estar
en el piso 120 se habrá movido no lo
sabes
entonces aquí me quiero regresar a mí a
una parte de mi pasado cuando mi esposa
y yo nos conocimos
y quiero que se imaginen una fiesta
solamente imagínense lo porque estamos
en la pandemia y ccoo vida y no deberían
de estar saliendo afuera y juntándose
con nadie más pero estamos en una fiesta
y yo llegué temprano porque había pagado
algo para los tacos de la pizza no me
acuerdo es total de que estaba al fondo
de la sala
serie empezó a llenar toda la sala todo
estaba completamente retocado detrás de
mí había un sillón donde me becado y así
me quedé cerca de las bebidas y por ahí
atrás había una lámpara muy bonita y al
verse a la lámpara me doy cuenta que
allá abajo hay una dama que se ve muy
buena onda y que está viendo hacia el
horizonte y luego de estar viendo el
horizonte se voltea conmigo y me dice
ven ven para acá
me quedé congelado dije tengo que pasar
esta sala lo más pronto posible pero
está llena de gente cómo le hago es más
cómo le harían ustedes bueno tienes un
par de opciones cuando menos una la más
evidente es que te abres paso a través
de la gente te va a tomar mucho tiempo
está en el horizonte muy claro dónde
quieres llegar pero está re pecado
entonces esto está va a tomar tiempo o
ir para allá
pero en fin puedes bailar lo que está
pasando a través de la cliente puede
seguir tomando de tu bebida puedes
platicar con otras personas ok eso es
una innovación claramente incremental
donde si te llevará a dónde quieres
llegar pero te va a tomar mucho tiempo
tienes una segunda opción
donde reúne toda la fuerza y el poder
universal y teletransportar de manera
inmediata e instantánea al lugar exacto
en el que querías tu estar es algo
completamente mágico y musical yo nunca
lo he visto pasar
ciertamente te sacaste una lotería
interdimensional a la que ni siquiera
habías comprado un boleto
ok eso es una innovación destructiva eso
es un gran brinco parece ser que eso es
lo que yo quería hacer en mi laboratorio
pero si lo pensamos hay otras opciones
si vemos alrededor nuestro vemos que
aquí atrás tenía ese sillón aunque
entonces me puedo subir arriba el sillón
caminar arriba de él se pueden regañar
este pudieras brincar hacia la mesa
tirar las bebidas no tiran ninguna
bebida y te pudieras agarrar de la
lámpara y caer mágicamente como
superhéroe penando te un poco y decirle
hola qué tal cómo está el betis este que
eso fue lo que lo que hice en by the way
y y este y eso tiene unas ciertas
características interesantes si nos
fijamos un poco uno los saltos hacia
dónde quieres llegar o hacia dónde te
quieres aproximar no son evidentes
tú tuviste que haber volteado hacia
atrás frente de ti a un lado ver qué era
lo que se encontraba en la orilla y ver
que era posible tal vez encontrar ese
camino que te llevará a donde quería
llegar oa un lugar muy cerca de donde tú
querías llegar
el segundo punto característica de esto
es de que está adyacente a ti ese camino
está pegado a ti si el sillón no hubiera
estado ahí hasta ahí se acaba el cuento
y no hubiera podido brincar del sillón a
la mesa y etcétera
y el tercer elemento de esto es que está
en el futuro tú tienes que hacer algo tú
tienes que accionar para poder ejecutar
todo este proceso y llegar a ese lugar a
dónde quieres llegar
entonces esta es la metodología que
típicamente sigue la naturaleza para
poder hacer sus mejoras evolutivas y esa
podría ser una metodología que me podía
llevar a mí a lograr las disrupciones
que yo quería entonces parecía ser que
una revolución no es más que la suma de
grandes o de pequeños brincos o de
medianos brincos parece ser que una
revolución no es más que la suma de
futuros adyacentes posibles
excelente ya tenemos un algoritmo ya
estamos teniendo un proceso que nos
permite llegar a nuestra revolución pero
como creas un futuro adyacente posible
lo que hay también es sencillo tenemos
tres pasos principales paso número uno
necesitas conocimiento
cuánto conocimiento todo el conocimiento
base posible que te permita a ti lograr
la revolución en esa área en donde tú le
quieres hacer aquí es donde mínimo se
tiene que caer a la escuela pero de
plano tienen que leer muchísimo más por
favor porque esa lectura ese
conocimiento te va a llevar al paso
número 2 que es debes de tomar acción
debes de tomar acción nada sucede hasta
que tú actúas e incluso cuando actúas lo
único que te garantiza es que algo va a
pasar pero no que pase lo que tú quieras
que pase pero ok ejecutas y eso te lleva
al elemento número 3 que es es
imprescindible fallar lo voy a repetir
es imprescindible fallar
el fallar te permite generar
conocimiento empírico conocimiento de la
realidad que te va a poder regresar acá
y que te van a hacer modificar tu
siguiente conjunto de acciones que te va
a acercar a la revolución o a la
innovación disruptiva que tú quieres
ok
pero bueno si lo pensamos también un
poquito más creo que hace falta un
cuarto elemento
y este cuarto elemento también es
sumamente importante y es que
no puedes ser crítico ni de ti ni de los
futuros adyacentes posibles que estás
tratando de crear
sobre todo no puede ser crítico de ti
porque que es un crítico un crítico es
alguien que hace una evaluación racional
o no del desempeño de otros
pero como puede ser crítico tú
y artista creador de futuros posibles si
uno de los elementos clave de crear esos
futuros es fallar
entonces quiero que aquí todos los que
estamos presentes hagamos un pacto
y es que quiero que nos compartamos
nuestros futuros posibles los tuyos los
míos y lo quiero hacer a través de una
tecnología viejísima pero con algo de
innovación
en este número de teléfono que están
viendo aquí en la pantalla con lo que un
robot ese robot cuando ustedes marquen
ese número de teléfono y por favor
marque en el número de teléfono con
ustedes marcas del número de teléfono el
robot les va a contestar y les va a
compartir un futuro adyacente mío o de
algunos de los que ya han escuchado esta
plática y te va a pedir a ti que
compartas en un minuto un futuro posible
tuyo un futuro posible que hayas querido
llevar a la realidad y que hasta que
escuchaste esta plática no te aventaste
hasta para decir si lo voy a crear ok
y eso me recuerda también algo que en
méxico nos dicen tal vez de muy jóvenes
que es que él hubiera no existe y tal
vez nos los dicen para que no saben
tenemos
pero yo creo que quisiera ser algo
encontrar aquí y quisiera decir que lo
hubiera si existen
él hubiera son los futuros posibles
sobre los cuales tú no tomaste una
acción
regresemos al lugar ese negro del cual
les hablé yo ahorita y creo que jamás
voy a poder transmitir que tan negro era
ese lugar pero no lugar muy negro
regresemos a ese lugar negro en donde yo
ya me daba por descontado
si no hubieran adquirido conocimiento si
no hubiera actuado si no me hubiera
permitido a mí fallar pues no hubiera
logrado crear empresas dar trabajos y
sobre todo hacer algo que es lo que me
llena a mí muchísimo que es transformar
ideas en realidades
entonces hablando de estos pasados
futuros y etcéteras les he estado
hablando ciertamente de mí incluso hasta
de mi esposa
y ambos ya
hemos logrado tener un niño pequeño que
en este momento tiene 8 años y al estar
hablando con ustedes me he dado cuenta
de que también está hablando con él
y que también estaba hablando con él en
un futuro
y en este futuro quisiera decir
aprende de este mundo y de sus personas
actuar actúa para llevar a cabo lo que
deseas lograr no seas ni hagas caso de
los críticos sobre todo los propios los
que llevas dentro de ti falla todo lo
que puedas fallar porque todos los
futuros son posibles en ti
gracias